well you know there's a famous quote by
Kanye he says I don't know what's better
getting paid or getting laid I know when
I focus on one the other is getting away
yeah so how do you divvy up your time
and your attention because it you've
been pretty candid you want to
repopulate the planet Elon Musk style
you want to get laid but you're also
very concerned with obviously hex and
making money so how do you balance your
time with that
luckily the mission that I have to
improve the World by fixing Finance
politics consensus networks you know
security getting people to take control
of their own Keys which you know defunds
the scammers competing against scams for
the same eyeballs because I have you
know pitches similar to theirs but we're
honest and they're garbage
so me making myself more popular
achieves both of those goals at the same
time so the end game is Instagram the
end game is digital it is global and
therefore to get I've thought about this
very deeply
you go to high school there's hot chicks
and then they get sucked off into the
suburbs by relationships and then no one
ever sees them again you don't see them
in the coffee shop you don't see them at
the club they no longer exist in society
this also will happen to your guy
friends once your guy friends like get
married to go to suburbs you'll never
see them again they're gone that's it
you might see each other once you're
mostly true yeah I barely see my married
friends that's it yeah they're just out
they're no longer a part of society so
what you have to do is if you want to
reach these people that are of the
severe hotness that don't exist in
society they're there they're alive they
have a house they have an electric bill
but they don't go in the public you've
got to reach them digitally and so
if you're not on social media or
otherwise doing direct messaging to
these people you are not going to have
them in your life and no one you know
will either because they live in a
bubble and the only people that see them
are maybe somebody that's at their like
tennis club or something otherwise they
don't exist I'm gonna break through that
bubble so that's
and this is kind of what promoters do
for nightclubs like this is kind of if
they're good at their job kind of what
they do trying to draw people out of
their homes into a public space
so the promotion that I do for crypto
and the promotion that I do for myself
personally to be more attractive they
have a lot of crossover
um I haven't figured out the outbound
thing yet like I probably need to just
have a team of guys like messaging
people will be cool to hang out with and
setting up cool events and then taping
it I think that's the end game pretty
much
I don't think there's a way to do it
better because I measure these things
like you can see who's doing well like
rockstars they I don't think they
actually do that well like the groupies
that show up aren't the hottest people
and you know maybe group reinteract I've
had
I don't know people that are rich or
heart maximalist groupies have turned
out to be really smart like nice you're
saying the girls who are like oh really
here's my pants the people that have
watched all my videos
pretty smart usually because oh yeah
they're not dummies right what you're
basically exact course and so then I
tend to respect them because they're
pretty and smart and then what more do
you want you know and likes you and
respects you for who you really are and
those past the flash or whatever like
that that turns around a lot like I I
like that so
when you say when you say what more do
you want what do you want out of a woman
like if you were to get married
hypothetical
you gotta hook up with girls she's got
to be interested number one you can't be
jealous it can't be she's gotta be happy
she gotta be flexible I argue enough on
the internet I don't need someone to
come home and argue with right like I
did all my arguing right so someone's on
my team not trying to check nuts and be
smarter than me it's like it's not gonna
happen not gonna try and check nuts try
more money it's not going to happen like
you you got to know your place you ain't
gonna be smarter you ain't gonna have
more money it's not happening so what do
you want them to be better at than you
um inner game mind management State
happiness when I'm not in public I'm not
happy hmm I'm frustrated nothing's going
good enough right I'm focusing on public
no when I'm alone when you're alone I'm
frustrated nothing's going good enough
nothing's like everything's messed up in
my brain because I'm focused on what's
wrong instead of what's right and I have
tons of stuff I could focus on to be
happy but then I'm not getting things
done
so I when I'm in public though when I'm
speaking to people my game's great I'm a
better human being I'm a better human
being here now talking to you guys and I
would be alone right and so when I'm in
public because you're on you're like I
gotta be on that game I gotta look
outside
what's good and positive and happy and
bringing value and having good posture
but when you're alone you're like I
gotta fix this I gotta fight with this
person so I'm a better human being when
I'm with people and if she's got that
figured out and it's just in general
happy it's going to bring great joy to
my life so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
[Music]